[Music]
when you wake up
you don't know that today would be the
day to change a life
grace please tell me what happened what
did he do to you
[Music]
I've been so lonely since my divorce I
can't love somebody wanna be loved you
need to get him out this house and meet
somebody you have the CDs in the night
light
and the best lighting in the room is
right here
okay hey is a beautiful sari
[Music]
tell me something I mean I know you've
had many young women I was just
wondering why me shouldn't the question
be why not
I was falling hard I don't even know
that a man could be that perfect it was
a well that's what everything I knew
what are you talking to grace they don't
like being checked up all
mr. Clyde would like to see you in the
conference room right away okay
you have 24 hours to return the money
where you're going to jail what somebody
got into account they got my passwords
somebody has stolen my identity I can't
believe you'd do this to me
I'm a husband you know the laws of this
state the money's mine
she got Fox you made this to me my age
low-hanging fruit
Greece we're outside the Holloway
Correctional Facility where grace waters
is being held something isn't adding up
I swear was done there was my body he
was gone pretty so there's so much more
of a story you knew something and you
didn't tell the police that's a crime
right
to our friends are you covering for her
objection your honor
this is unfair it's your job to walk
into that courtroom and make it fair
darling if you see the devil won't you
tell them I'm coming home
[Music]